so I know you're gonna be mad but just
hear me out before you go mad I'm so
happy this is when Beth was happiest
curled up on her bed with her Chihuahua
Yoda but moments like this came between
bouts of depression and anxiety the
struggle ended with Beth taking her own
life in April this year I mean back a
really close she tell me anything a
boyfriend she was living with a
boyfriend if anything Beth's future was
good she would tell me when she was
anxious she felt loved - they slept well
less anxious I didn't cry today
karen has suffered two tragedies her
husband Ian killed himself four years
ago it was Beth who discovered her
stepfathers body I think we
underestimated the impact that on Beth
and I think it was a far reaching and
assuming the struggle and it was only
after um she died that we found a diary
and some of the things she'd written by
flashbacks and about panic attacks in
2018 some six and a half thousand
suicides were registered in the UK
that's 686 more deaths than the previous
year an eleven point eight percent
increase men account for almost
three-quarters of these deaths and in
recent years the number of young women
under 25 taking their own lives has
increased in 2012 there were 106
silicides and in 2018 that had gone up
to a hundred and eighty eight you have
to prioritize in a protest mental health
this rises all the more alarming
considering the efforts to destigmatize
mental health everyone from celebrities
to the royal family have backed
campaigns
professor Appleby leads the national
suicide prevention strategy for England
well in the last few years the suicide
rate has been falling so we assumed that
the the greater openness about suicide
was having a benefit allowing people to
come forward and seek help when they
needed it so it is a surprise that it's
now gone up and maybe that tells us that
talking on its own isn't enough the
reasons behind suicide are never
straight forward continuing to challenge
attitudes will help
[Music]
I have to say long thing let's talk
about it and yeah as a mom I didn't want
people to join dancer if we can save one
life with somebody by talking about it
it saves one human person one any and
anybody to feel that the only option is
to dari strong Ashish Joshi Sky News